bang-bang what's up guys lunch money
time well while she's trying to get rich
rest of us just trying to get a lunch
money right I'm here the beautiful
beautiful beautiful beautiful and
intelligent plain Tamara Nova who has on
a leather sleeveless shirt can we talk
about the fashion choices nope
a leather sleeveless shirt didn't even
know they made those but you got black
on so you're following the dress code I
appreciate it
don't forget lunch money's now sponsored
by block-by-block five.com slash lunch
money go and take out a u.s. dollar loan
against your crypto they will give you a
twenty five hundred dollar bonus you can
also use their interest bearing account
6.8% oh just kidding eight point six
percent interest on an interest bearing
account it's a no-brainer go to posit
crypto or your digital dollars all right
let's get into the fun do you know why I
wore this today why did you wear a black
sleeveless leather shirt to show you
exactly what I think that Jeff Bezos
will wear to the hearing guns out let's
go what's going on with her sun's out or
as some people say sun's out thighs out
no no it's not
sun's out thighs out those short shorts
going on so hurts remember our friendly
company hurts that was bankrupt turns
bankrupt hurts i suspended its plan to
sell up to five hundred million dollars
in shares after the sec voiced concern
about the deal and launched a review
what the hell are they doing well if
you're hertz and you're sitting there
and you're trying to protect your
shareholders and pay off your debt and
everyone's bidding up your stock and
it's exploding then you sit there and
say hey if we sell stock into the market
right now we could raise a bunch of
money they went to a court approved a
judge approved it that they could do it
but it's capitalizing on idiot retail
investors so the sec said wall time
outlets reviews so does that mean that
hurts can technically get out of
bankruptcy because of this well the way
bankruptcy works is it doesn't mean the
company goes away bankruptcy is just
protection hey it's literally calling a
timeout with creditor
so that they can reorganize it usually
the equity gets wiped out there's new
owners that come in and then they go in
to rebuild the company with all the
assets what they're trying to do is this
is like a very unique situation where
people are buying a bankrupt stock in
the public markets like this and they're
trying to capitalize it but the SEC said
no we're not let me rephrase it didn't
say no we're not gonna let you do it
they said we're gonna look at this
deeper and that has caused them to
suspend the stock sale got it rent
freeze okay so did you mess up no I hit
a paywall again so New York City is
basically trying to after the pandemic
trying to freeze rent for two million
tenants for an entire year meaning that
they can't they don't have to pay their
rent or that it's not gonna go up I
think it's not gonna go up that's fine
I mean I tend to think that in many
cases you should let the free market run
the problem is that you've got all
mission going on in the market and so
therefore landlords are just jacking up
prices I mean so you see this in San
Francisco seus in New York where there's
kind of these rent is controlled so you
can only go up so much each year and it
protects people rioted and so in this
case like if they're gonna say hey no
one can raise their rents who really
screws as it screws the landlord's but
nope so some tenant groups some tenant
groups had called for a rent decrease
but the board had not has not approved a
rent increase in its more than 50 year
history yeah I feel like that's not
gonna happen in New York City no and
again by the way I hate this whole idea
of like we're gonna use regulation and
laws to manipulate markets and help one
group while we screw over another group
right like look at the end of the day
you sign the contract that says I'm
gonna rent this place and here so I'm
gonna do if you lose your job and all
this up it's horrible like it it is so
painful right and obviously it causes
problems but at the same time the
landlord has expenses to pay to the bank
and you know we've got almost a million
times so I think you just gotta be
careful and we
you got to do is you've got to protect
both sides of the transaction but do it
with as little manipulation in the
market as possible
hungry fair fair Nikita I think that's
what the TV show is called I was trying
to remember La Femme Nikita I think it's
the name of the TV show she's a woman
who's like like a Jackie Chan wannabe I
think if I remember correctly and she
wears a leather shirt La Femme Nikita if
I remember correctly I could be saying
that wrong but go ahead it was on USA he
used to be on there with suits La Femme
Nikita a couple other shows my computer
wasn't about today I would look it up um
so the Justice Department proposed the
rollback of legal protections that
online platforms have enjoyed for more
than two decades in effort to make tech
companies more responsible and how they
police content that means that the
department's changes are designed to
make things like Facebook and Twitter
and whatever address illicit and harmful
content content on their site or contact
others I don't think that they should be
in the business of doing they're okay
but hold on can I can I just add a
caveat sure you know how just came out
with Twitter audio which we're about to
talk about
yeah actually I'll save it but do you
think that the platform should be
placing this stuff honestly here's where
I draw the line if it's illegal if it's
child trafficking drugs actual violence
not the threat of violence not the
insinuation of violence but actually
like I shoot you on and the video goes
on the internet whatever there should be
some level of hey what you are about to
engage in is illegal hey this pool
whatever but they should still allow it
it should still be on there and the
whole thing is you do not want to get in
the world where Mark Zuckerberg Jack
Dorsey you know sundar whoever is making
the decisions about what we have access
to don't want them to be the arbiters of
truth but it's not just truth or you
know policing me but it's just stuff
like when I log on to Twitter I don't
want to see somebody inciting violence
or killing somebody else
like that's not what I use these
platforms for so there has to be so sort
of like but just because you don't but
just because you don't want it doesn't
mean that they shouldn't allow it right
if somebody can post it somewhere else
you don't have to look at it you can
block that person if it comes across
your feed whatever it goes back to the
idea of we should never infringe on one
person's civil rights right or their
civil liberties like it is not worth
stopping a crime or doing anything for
the infringement of our rights and
ultimately we have the right to free
speech we have the right to see this
stuff we have to get out of the world of
the population looking to tech companies
for the government or River to protect
us like you're in charge of your content
diet if you don't want to see stuff
don't go on the internet there's a lot
of nuance and I think you're making a
little bit black and white in my opinion
but it's not like that okay let me ask
one question if you were running one of
the tech companies where would you draw
the line in terms of what you would be
comfortable policing and where you would
say basically what like the freedom of
speech allows an incitement of violence
is not covered by freedom of speech by
the way incitement of violence I don't
think it's right word but inciting
violence inciting violence I actually if
we are in a crowded theater and I scream
fire that is not protected under freedom
of okay but if somebody says I think we
should kill terrorists is that not
inciting violence I don't know no I'm
generally don't know right but my point
is that there of course but like that's
part of this is hot like we're again
where do you draw the line follow
whatever has been passed and agree like
agreed to by a court okay I don't think
it's that easy but I don't think
anything's easy I generally I generally
were we're in the one myth the content
police by the way we should give them a
better name than content police like if
we've space force we should have like
content force go ahead what's going on
Twitter on you so Twitter is
to add voice messages to tweets allowing
you to record up to 140 seconds of audio
get it because in 40 seconds I got it 40
characters okay but hold on I have two
things one I read a newsletter today and
it was really funny somebody said you
know everyone is saying hey Twitter
please give us the option to edit tweets
and then they're like eh actually we're
just gonna give you Twitter audios and
then the second thing is speaking of
content police if Twitter is going to
start policing or moderating content
isn't is gonna make it much harder for
them to moderate that content whenever
make it harder to I generally think that
this is a good idea from Twitter what I
don't know is will it be successful over
the long term you and I have been
talking about like the whole idea of
when you're on Twitter
you're very kind of text driven that the
consumption mode that you're in and now
all of a sudden you've got to switch to
be a audio as well which is a little
different the second thing is some of
that we were recently talking to brought
up the idea of like it's actually a
double opt-in of content consumption
meaning that when you post the audio it
sits on my feet but I can't actually
hear it almost like click on it to hear
it whereas a tweet could just go through
my feet and I see it whether I wanted to
or not so I think that's interesting
but look audio is coming we're seeing
audio explode all over the place
everything from Clubhouse to this to
some other companies that were aware of
podcast obviously so for a major
platform to get into audio makes sense
it's just a question of you know what
does that look like and then you know I
am holding out for the audio only feet I
think that there's gonna be a good day
where they just say a press play and
then it's all of the audio tweets you
can just listen it could be interesting
all right what's going on to lift okay
so ride sharing company lyft is
promising to switch to 100% electric
vehicles by 2030 now they're saying this
just because they're trying to force the
hand of regulators and legislators on
whatever but I mean that's a big promise
I I do not make promises lately that's
pretty bold so one this great idea in
terms of if they can do it to this would
require a
mence lifts from multiple players not
just lifts but obviously car
manufacturers lawmakers local cities and
states and you know regulators always
kind of stuff
three is I'm with you that when people
make promises like this you know the one
thing I wish that they would do I wish
that they would put they said what
they're gonna do and they set a timeline
so they're making a projection or a
promise in a specific oh I wish that
they would add a penalty a self-imposed
penalty so they would say something like
we're gonna go fully electric in by 2030
by January 1st 2030 if we do not we will
donate a hundred million dollars to
whatever oh love that right and so
basically what it does is like they got
real skin in the game yeah you got like
the accountability now by the way it's
going to charity a lot of people say why
don't you still make the money anyways
but it's it's less about like a
regulation driven penalty and it's more
about saying we're serious about this
and by the way there is a quote unquote
cost if we don't hit this we get the
benefit of all the press right now and
and kind of get people excited but if we
don't hit it there's gonna be a penalty
right not a bad idea we should try and
doing that with you and you say I
promise to put my dishes away when you
don't do it what could the penalty be I
should have to sit on the couch by
myself you have to wear this shirt no I
shouldn't have to sit on the couch all
by myself and watch TV all right what's
going on Kim Kardashian speaking of TV's
Kim kardashian-west signed a deal with
Spotify an exclusive podcast deal people
are speculating that it could be about
criminal justice reform because that's
what she's been focusing on lately um
they do not think it's as large as how
much you getting paid that's what I want
to know how much is she getting paid so
it's it's not likely to be worth more
than a hundred million dollars though it
was unclear what it is why would she
ever get paid a hundred million dollars
Kim Kardashian Kim Kardashian is smaller
it has a smaller audience than Joe Rogan
when it comes to audio and video
platforms she is way bigger on social
media but an in long-form content Joe
Rogan has bigger eyes people have been
watching the Kardashians since like 12
years ago okay how many people watch the
Kardashians
Joe Rogan his episodes are bigger see
this is what people don't realize is the
people on YouTube there are certain
people who had way way bigger audiences
1.3 million total viewers every Sunday
night I think though Joe Rogan gets over
a million views on every single
interview he posts on YouTube just just
the video they're not equal at all
that's not including all the audio
downloads he gets all the stuff get
outta here Joe Rogan is bigger than the
Kardashians fact check it I got the data
show me the responsibly when you ask she
her name has more recognition than Joe
Rogan in the media no no look regular
people like my cousin in Bulgaria knows
Kim Kardashian he does not know Joe
you're looking at anecdotally what I'm
telling you is that because that's all
driven by social media what I'm telling
you is that what matters for what she's
trying to do right here Joe Rogan is way
bigger ok it doesn't matter but she's
filled so what does this say about
Spotify that they keep trying to get
these big names to start podcasts or
remove their podcasts it's the only
thing that they can do to try to do what
they want to do which is they want they
want to be the go-to place for audio
they had Daniel act when I'm the invest
like the best podcast with Patrick Ross
Shaughnessy and he basically was like
look we were doing music and we're like
wait audios to say like they compete
with each other podcast and music cuz
now some people don't listen to music on
their commute they actually go and do
you remember when spot if I meet that
big play in podcast a few years ago they
acquired gimlet for I believe three
hundred million and also anchor and
there was one more you want to hear some
you wanna hear my heart take what
Spotify is doing everything that's good
for them this is horrible for open
podcast networks making everything
exclusive like this is the smart
business move for Spotify I ultimately
think it will not prove to be right
because I think that Spotify is trying
to pull off a Microsoft they're trying
to create this closed-end system where
all the content is within their
ecosystem and Joe Rogan isn't on other
platforms all its kind of stuff but I
always always always believed that the
openness wins so open Internet wins open
currency Williams open audio it is a
sner I don't quite know there's a huge
difference between me having to go on
Apple podcasts or YouTube versus Spotify
Minh speak I gonna make you pay in some
cases so are you gonna get like Gaea
Spotify yeah on my phone oh I don't I
don't pay for it now yeah but do you use
it yeah you do for what music okay where
you listen to podcast
Apple Apple okay are you gonna switch
all of your listening on podcast to
Spotify if they have really good ones
I'm not um platform agnostic I am all
about the quality if they move if you
moved your podcasts to Spotify I would
not only listen but I would pay it's on
Spotify oh yeah for free I just listened
to you live through it here literally
Daniel Daniel hack is looking for people
like you like you're like you're the
Turk cuz he's gonna trick you into
paying for Spotify yes he is Kim
Kardashian Daniel when Kim Kardashian
starts her podcast you're gonna we did
watch that Kim Kardashian documentary
about criminal justice pretty cool she's
yeah by the way Joe Rogan's bigger than
Kim Kardashian market I got the receipts
don't worry
Paulina's bigger than pomp fact you got
the receipts fact if I wasn't on the
show one day it would be the best
performing show we've ever had
alright guys that's it for lunch money
today well while she's trying to get
rich the rest of us just trying to get
her lunch money right clean it will
hopefully be here tomorrow be kind to
your friends
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
don't forget lunch money's now sponsored
by block 5 so go check them out there's
a link in the description that you can
click on I'm an investor a user and a
huge fan what you're a bigger fan of
block fire than you are of me block wise
my second favorite thing in the world
behind polina
they've got 3 products they can give you
a u.s. dollar loan you can earn up to
eight point six percent interest on an
interest-bearing account or you can buy
and sell crypto currencies on their
crypto exchange I personally use the
interest-bearing account there's not
very many places where you'll find up to
eight point six percent interest on a
deposit in an interest-bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6% it's pretty
compelling so click on the link in the
description say thanks to the folks that
block
if I subscribe to our channel like the
video annoy plane in the comment and
we'll see you guys tomorrow and be kind
to your friends